citizens of the reject Nation it is time to dive
into a newer DC animated film tell me John have
you seen Injustice I have not I've heard its
reputation but I've not read nor played it's
all going to be fresh to me I have not played I
have read but I have not seen so I've only got a
third of this so and Injustice is a huge spanning
story I've only read the first two volumes It Is
by Tom Taylor it is a book I enjoy very very
much have not played the game so we are gonna
be sitting down to watch Injustice right now and
yes we know we've been on a DC Animated Universe
kick we are not done with it but we're like you
know what let's mix it up it's a Multiverse we're
gonna dive into some more present stuff so in
the comments let us know what else you want us
to watch let us know which the dcau which of these
standalones which of the anything leave a comment
is what I'm saying also hit that notification
Bell so you know when we drop another one of
these the only way these get made is you guys
watching them so share with your friends because
sharing is caring you excited for this one I'm so
excited I was also excited we will leave a like
and for people to check things out on the patreon
where you can see everything that gets cut out of
these little highlight reels full experience
of us watching it including resting faces
that's how we watch it's pretty exciting
stuff so become a patron experience us
watching and help out the channel which is very
appreciated without further Ado Let Us injustice
[Music]
2021 I think this is the newest one we've watched
what is the future of DC animation look like
the recent past that's how I love my
Futures man everything's Nostalgia
this was the intro in front of the live
action movies too right yeah [Music]
that's what I feel like who's
gonna look like is that that scope
so bright not for long a beautiful
day why did you say that descriptor
Metropolis it's fun to see animation style
change in the last 10 years heavier lines
weird you're you're pregnant oh we're
pregnant we are we're pregnant mostly
you but I helped [Laughter] woke Superman
knows how to say it it's all you clerk a
broad world view is important but people will
notice if I'm constantly patrolling Oxford
who's his voice Channing Tatum
who is that not a bad choice
uh I like that it was a red blanket or
a red card because it's a little little
moment of soups he should have grabbed the
curtains threw it on this will have to do
Injustice I'm worried at how
light and fluffy that just started
[Applause] [Music]
The Joker isn't Metropolis I'm here
to find out why I have news Bruce
Lois is pregnant how your hands didn't
Tremble When you faced doomsday they
are now oh world's greatest detective and
you're grinning like an idiot say cheese
looks suspicious everyone wear glasses
you don't look suspicious enough
one more [Music]
whoa imagine meeting you here hello
[Music] vacation is so fun pudding only the
very best for you that's how they tie this yeah
oh wow oh wow through the lens koi we did
these are supposed to be fun we did warn you
it's a light story from the DC Universe oh
Superman watch he has her help me please
right to business I need as many of you
as we can spare a metropolis a woman is
missing you want the whole Justice League
on a missing person yes what's up Green
Arrow yeah who is this woman Batman she's
one of ours her name is Lois Lane one of
us one of us flash we're searching
for Lois Lane in Metropolis straight
out of the show that was cool I need
you to search everything Underground
said burn Ave John Byrne one of the
great DC and Marvel artists hey my man
I found scarecrow he's dead Joker toxin his lab
has been ransacked bummer something's wrong oh no
oh yeah [Music] love it
oh wow wow they just jigsawed Barry Allen
stolen a submarine with Harley
Quinn they took Lois with them oh
my god get Aquaman on the case yeah where's he at
[Music]
a little Snyder left for you yeah
yeah and a little Superman and Lois
where is she no
no I will not let you hurt anyone oh
scarecrow's fear toxin mixed with Kryptonite
particles what did you it'll be my masterpiece
Superman stop whatever you're seeing it's
not real oh god oh no please don't tell me
oh my God
what is what's the scar
[Music]
oh
God why'd you tell me about this coin
that was that that was the moment I was
like well let's see how John takes this
we started out so joyous and it escalates from
here so uh well Justice we're just gonna break
through the ceiling all the way down into hell
yeah this has always been about us why do this to
him I thought I'd try a game on easy mode for once
as easy as beating a puppy to death with a kitten
I killed him no that madman orchestrated
this he's responsible will you keep her
safe of course what what is there to keep
safe now I mean you want to honor her I Fair
sorry I'm so distraught I mean you
should be it's got so many feelings
you've had an unfathomable loss
you need time to process it
oh yeah is this Hal yeah please don't do
something you'll regret for the rest of your life
I already have uh oh someone took everything
from you didn't they and look at what you
became what do you think he'll become a God who
deluded himself into believing he was just a man
the joke's on you and the world
oh my God
I think uh murder him right here
[Laughter] um
[Laughter]
Comics are for kids oh yeah Comics are wholesale
and video games are fanciful this is
a video game and a comic what a story
I'm gonna try and contain myself
the punchline line that image from
the comic is so like super punching
The Joker Is Such like a comic moment
sure I'm gonna go grab the comic
immediately it's so good Tom Taylor
keeping a low profile [Music]
oh yeah get ready for a
permanent low profile [Music]
yep just got it the the
double meaning of that joke
I feel like that would still hurt to
get hit in the nuts with them yeah
so where are we going to a secret
location I won't be secret for Long
hey how come your little beard
looks both ridiculous and cute
what's this one do
well done Hawkeye he's got the skills Jamie Renner
threat of instant nuclear death hanging over every
single one of us new killer new killer glad
he's doing this oh how many times did you catch
this Joker your laws are weak and ineffective
Twisted by evil people to escape just punishment
I mean not a bad argument you'll throw away
everything the Justice League stands for I
won't be held back by ideals that don't
protect the innocent you're grieving
we were wrong
beautiful psychology and character use and
like what a story and beautiful anime beautiful
animation Superman and Wonder Woman deposited
president Hussein at the Hague for trial well
that happened yep where I am you're in the arrow
cave Arrow cave is a stupid name though Batman has
the bat cave that makes sense bats live in caves
arrows don't uh Whatchamacallit inanimate okay
call it the quiver call it the Quivers
it goes that's actually much better
that's so annoying I love that 50 years in the
era the quiver monsters will not be
allowed to roam free finally quiet
[Laughter]
sorry plastic man's the best no one has the
right to take innocent lives no one it's
over [Music] can we talk about how you took the
innocent life of your badass five o'clock shadow
it was beautiful Superman and Wonder Woman
destroyed every piece of military equipment
declaring it an arms free zone this is like
the boys if they were still moral somehow
right kind of yeah there's characters you know
like it's a fascinating this is so Palestine
Superman crime and you and Superman decide these
punishment I believe my time with the Justice
League is over oh most of the magical Heroes
feel the same way everyone has to make their own
choice about this at last we agree on something
I want to hear what Mr terrific had to say is the
smartest man Justice for terrific Sterling K Brown
live-action Mr terrific make it happen James Gunn
here
oh
and that's when the boy scout crashed
our tea party what do you propose Bob
this is tricky it's crazy right
yeah whoa on the floor old man
was that necessary
everyone get to me for Evac now
it is upon myself and I just check me
out real quick through this badassery
here where is he alive he stays that way
if you stop interfering with governments
father is the last link to
my Humanity if I lose him
let your friends help you are you really helping
them hey what's up where's Gary King exactly
time to talk personal space your highness
nah why don't you walk out of here
and do it slow for me well
there's no place to hide prove it
hey nice you have to understand I had orders the
kind you can't say no to where's Jonathan Kent
Bolivia was that like a Suicide Squad mission for
him oh I wonder if that is that the kind of order
you can't say no to yeah ten square kilometers
of endless reflected sky so beautiful [Music]
ah that was dope nice it was incredibly
stupid you do not touch a man's parents
he wouldn't touch me the public
perception really that naive there'd
be no evidence and no one will think
to look for your body on Saturn dude
have you been here for the
past 20 minutes come on now
you're trying to hurt your opponents
which I'm trying not to take personally
I was taught by the League of Assassins in
racial ghoul yeah how's that working out for you
how are you is he here yeah and broodier than
usual we'll give you some space come on Damien
oh yeah [__] you killed a man Clark
not a man a monster we can't decide who
dies one death it always starts with
one your parents were murdered Bruce
they couldn't be there for you what's your excuse
oh boy oh show me your hand come on don't be you
Airline fracture of the third finger
you'll be fine in three weeks good to know
jeez I'd like you to be there at my
side I'm sorry Clark I can't do that
can we watch absolutely Amish now I'm
dying to see if goody and finishes her
spice rack buffer rum spiringer
hahaha that delivery was so good
you're spying on me through my TV for how long
that's unimportant not to me sure he's taking him
we're out of time I've decided to move the worst
criminals to a secure facility they won't threaten
anyone again oh boy as long as we're going to
help Superman burn Arkham to the ground you're
13. how old is the darkest thing in this cave ever
considered for a single second that you might be
wrong father well have you I've spent like a
lifetime considering this Damien I just love
the different perspectives so quickly yeah yeah
and it makes perfect sense that Damien would be
on Superman's side yeah young impressional
angry you were never as stubborn as him
God to be that stubborn a person
has to be directly related to you
now let's go defend a bunch of psychotic
killers from the world's greatest heroes bars
Tom Taylor's currently writing Nightwing the
guy that wrote this in the first place and
it's the best Nightwing's been in years it's
so good I'm coming with to bring Superman to
Justice or die trying either or because I'm
a hero now hero Harley oh yep yep yep are
you insane let me answer that question with an
action that reveals character what oh oh dude no
such chaos what are you doing bringing criminals
to Justice I'm standing with Superman look who
you're standing with Bane Killer Croc and whoever
that is uh calendar man is important in one Arc
Superman's got a scar now don't you do you feel
it the release that comes with it the freedom to
do anything you want oh is that jazz yeah making
a point Victor zaz David sass laugh where are you
taking them all you need to know is that it's
escape proof oh my all right Riddler time to go
EMP the bat bad EMP you'd always be ready to
take on the league the data stamp on the virus
you uploaded it the day we
met what that's low sure
oh no oh no I recommend putting
aside our differences for now
oh boy Clayface
extremely painful for me
there's your guy there's
your guy born on a Monday oh
no your guy if you harm one hair on I mean
aside from the hand it's still clenching
that's awesome
damn it Joe manganillo
I think that was Will Smith Oh Deadshot sorry
it's okay it's okay I got you you're not Bobby
oh [Laughter] yeesh Nightwing Gracie get up
hello the greatest Duo of all time [Music]
he won't be coming back on a Monday
could be your Frankenstein zombie guy
always get away from him oh is he actually
dead I thought I could redeem you I was wrong
yeah don't bother coming back to the bat cave
I'm exhausted we should we should pause I've
been playing this as a game and like just
enduring Nightwing is dead he'll need someone
you're his best friend talk to him I can't
too much has happened I love how well it knows
the characters like Superman would still try
yeah no this is this is lovely in a lot
of ways and the characterizations and the
debates yeah the psychology of right and wrong
and stop stop John Wick chapter four don't be
Batman don't be the mask let it out just for
tonight let yourself fall apart oh those lyrics
sound like lyrics oh Beth almost made me cry
right there one for all the more you know
bummer
bummer it's all okay now welcome to Grayson I
ramakrishna hey you must transform to Grace is
Dick Grayson gonna become dead man where's
my man Boston your soul shall be infused
your mind with my knowledge Moon Knight [Laughter]
but now you shall be called dead wig that away
all right I take it back it was worth him dying
payoff always kill him if he's gonna be coming
I offer my loyalty and my support your vision
of the future my grandfather has never bowed to
anyone this is a big deal you should know that's
uh it's kind of a thing I'd never Ally myself with
a Villain Like You how do we change his mind we
wait time and Circumstance will change Superman's
mind for us and I will be ready how very Zen
of you I mean he lives a long time you gotta
you learn to come I'm trying to map the Multiverse
there are infinite Earths oh well we designate our
Earth Earth One it stands to reason that our other
selves would do the same and they're all in crisis
I want to get rid of guns you
could never get rid of all the guns
people would resent us and they'd be
alive to do that check some would fight
let them come then with sticks and visual
metaphors and imprison anyone who speeds
traffic fatalities are huge check lock up everyone
who leaves a dangerous dog Unchained oh finally
we kill anyone who doesn't recycle yes we're Swamp
Thing at he's down how great is Mr terrific you're
not going to help me no sir I am not oh dude I
love that character so much uh yeah I want more
cool
the bath cave behave Harley
in the Fortress of Solitude there's a red Sun
Cannon it's rake and incapacitate even Superman
can we back up toward the thing that we need is
in Superman's man cave we'll have to break in
hello Christmas morning your president is using
a piece for his purposes [Music] we never learn
America what are you doing I don't want to waste
time turning those ships around when you can do it
with a phone call you can't just oh yeah yes I can
yes we can you must know I wouldn't let it stand
you're distracting me [Music]
glad that's over let's go there for a second you
say impenetrable Fortress
all I hear is candy store
that's right every line of dialogue does
so much like character building flexing
like they're so good at this you should go
quickly we're leaving what about the fate of
the world Superman's not thinking clearly if he
thinks even for a moment that would God oh man
you're all under arrest I don't think so
the atom has entered your skull with
a microscopic Shard of kryptonite
wow you'll make sure you don't do anything
else wow perhaps I can be of assistance oh
damn it breathe This is highly concentrated
chemotherapeutic gas oh no of course
the microscopic terrorists [Applause] whoa
this is gonna be floating around in his
head forever mushy just living
there what's left of the atom
[Music] oh
[Music] what oh no dad
no [Music] oh my God let them go it was an
accident try and forgive them oh I love you son
oh they must be brought to
Justice allow me to help
it's just from now on any hero that doesn't pledge
loyalty to the Justice League will be considered
a fugitive wow fascist man it is driving me nuts
trying to figure out it's like so specific like I
can almost see it Superman has greeted a police
state and Allied himself with raishal ghoul
not what I wanted yeah that's pretty bad what I
wanted [Laughter] like it's so Grim in certain
parts but so fun in other ways so good so
good [Music] you're gathering in his name
[Applause] oh boy
and that's the last annual
Gathering of the Juggalos [Laughter]
homelander stop absolute power
Green Arrow was hurt and you left
him there he had a hole in his head
try me yeah yeah well they just got snacks
and [__] it's the saddest meeting in the
Justice League it's the Justice League now it's
where they're at the beef jerky League to free
their inventor Mr terrific from Superman's prison
I've learned it's located in the Marianas Trench
wow there's only one hero not allied
with Superman who has the powers to
get there he's been hiding here
for days ah you knew [Laughter]
please hey ladies oh my oh I give you a meso
imagine one of these in every city in town
carrying out your orders in every household
Amazon tested in a small town Amazon's Amazo
named meso did racial goal name Amanda
I feel like you could have shopped that
Ben shorts for Plastic Man you now
hey look I found the key
that's handy
[Music] let's go we need to break the glass I
thought you were like the third smartest man in
the world it's keeping the water out [Laughter]
you know what you're doing don't move we're out
there's one problem solved now
the trench would flood pretty
much immediately that's that's pretty deep thick
so cool dick is always a highlight man yeah
it's just awesome always like
permanently awesome any form
flattered but nice tattoo though it's not
a tattoo oh it's a it's a stick on tattoo
it's an iPad okay this thing looks really
thin is it strong enough probably probably
thank you
playing around the world you killed these children
because they angered you no I killed them because
the lesson had to be learned I have to be strong
you said it's an interesting dynamic between
these two specifically yeah the woman like
the Corn Festival the old Corn Fest
oh oh that's the small town you
want to test out a Mesa win my dude
I should hope to say Earl past the woe
is the kid who swiped a candy bar oh
destroy him that's it oh
wow wow
America
the flag behind him and everything
oh Potential Threat to Authority Corn
Fest is ruined it's popcorn Fest now
take the robot offline now it's malfunctioning
Amazo is functioning perfectly it is you you who
are not what I neglected to tell you is that
it can also duplicate your ability oh yeah
boy [Music]
[Music]
am I maybe glad to see you I'm conflicted
yeah oh well that's metal Amazon
[Music]
that's a dead fan agarium that is rough
that was like a Hawkman even spoke
like a Grindhouse movie is the cratering alone
wow
oh boy [Music]
oh no
oh my man
can he breathe in space I don't think he breathes
we'll keep the thing occupied you're a freaking
guy in a suit everyone needs to follow the plan
foreign
yes Queen he's my father
disappoint me no I guess that's just
the way it is with family not bad Damian
oh boy more powerful than a locomotive
oh proof in the pudding there it is cool
we need Plastic Man sweet
oh cool you is it really you
in the spiritual flesh sure
that's awesome you've got this boy
it's just like building blocks yeah
yeah well done third level medium
oh boy
[Music]
[Music] oh nice that's a whip animation
oh [Music] Carly whoa whoa
oh my God oh my God [Applause] [Laughter]
that's what you got to do sometimes
sit back and let me do this wait for it
[Music]
there you go you're better than I am you always
were I've gotta go now watch your feet and
remember you don't have to kill everyone you fight
hahaha I'll try it your way you two no the battle
is one is it at least they died Heroes unlike you
terrorists who will go to jail for your crimes
what might they helped us Stand Down
finally stop this madness be a freaking hero
[Music]
huh
39 Superman
actually we're worth one what are
we 22. everyone's Earth one I'm
deeply sorry for your losses but
you're on the wrong side of this
no one is talking me out of this
yeah we can be stubborn sometimes
oh yeah
yep yep oh my God oh yeah
some of this is Gonna Knock the
Earth out of its orbit right
oh my God this goes so freaking hard
ah
I can't you're holding back you always
held back oh nice nice POV [Music]
Oppenheimer yeah that would be the concern
one holds back you think I'll stop because
someone will talk me out of it yes
yep hello Clark oh other Lois oh no
oh my you're not Lois and you're not my Clark
he died stopping Brainiac oh my how many people
husbands wives and children
will you kill for peace Clark
yep
just posing what have I done
oh man I deserve death you don't get off that easy
you deserve justice I'll stay wherever you put me
oh
buddy maybe we've all earned a second
chance oh what's gotten into you
just let it happen be in the
moment PDA Batman [Music]
flat line oh wow Injustice I am I am wrong Out
Boy I am Justin Hartley that's who Superman was
an Anson Mel's Batman Mount okay Justin Hartley
interesting where would I know Justin Hartley uh
Eastern Mrs us which is where I know I'm from
okay okay he was Green Arrow on uh Smallville
okay uh oh wait no it's the Aquaman I think he
was Aquaman either way he was in the Smallville
era he's on the Smallville uh I yeah this is us
is like my main thing from knowing him okay okay
damn she's good yeah absolutely that was intense
that was a whole Yuri was a Shazam Flash and
mirror Master look at all these like multicast
these are talented voice actors Jillian Jacobs is
Harley Quinn and Kevin Pollock is the Joker damn
hell yeah not bad Janet Varney is a Wonder Woman
that was so intense that was yeah overwhelming in
a good way and yeah like a fun way but also like
yeah just like I am exhausted a little bit they
came at you yeah and like it's it's Relentless
and and it does I think it plays really well on
the themes so that like if you didn't know these
characters at all it would still work as like
a debate and just like an impossible situation
but also knowing I mean you know you know the
characters like super intimately I know the
characters to varying degrees but even still
just having all those notes in there it does
hit that much harder because they do seem at
least from from my point of view so good at
using yeah like the intrinsic qualities of the
characters to inform all that others yeah and
to create the ironies and the tragedies and Tom
Taylor just plays chess like he's playing such a
long game with all these characters they're all
doing their different purposes and everything
like builds and builds and builds like every
single character that spoke had a beautiful
moment of like what they are and what their
worldview is and it's not just like a one-to-one
it's like a one to Thirty like there's so many
perspectives on every situation which is real life
yeah like he masterfully handles DC characters
yeah that was gorgeous and and yeah for another
like these movies are all like at least under
you know an hour 20 and like this felt so thick
it just felt like a longer movie in a good way
yeah you feel like you got the arcs you needed
to to justify these moments yeah you feel like
you got emotion you feel like you got you know
ideas and stuff you even got freaking humor amid
all this Grim crazy so many moments of levity that
you need to enjoy the experience of like oh yeah
it's like this was like the most maybe not the
no it's pretty dark like yeah you know you we
watched uh justice league dark last week and
I mean that had like when you whenever you go
hellish yeah there was like certain dark yeah
yeah it's like not exactly there is Horror in this
but this isn't yeah as horror-centric of aesthetic
as that is but yeah like this is philosophically
harv yeah no 100 like in a in a different way than
something like the boys is because that's also
like at the you know satirical like everyone's
irreverent and [__] but like you know this
is like what if you know the uh for the most
part quintessential versions of these characters
as they are were put into these uh ideological
positions to use their powers in such devastating
ways and so yeah it's like it's not the same as
watching a homelandering like merch but it does
happen sort of like Oh and it does play into
that conversation in an interesting way and I
love the escalation of like what he's willing
to do how that changes how it evolves how he sees
wrong and how that changes and evolves and I love
Batman's always like Batman's wrong about a lot of
things in my opinion but that's my opinion and I
love that Batman gets to stay like a moral compass
in this story because everyone else like he's our
only eye line he's our only like True North yeah
and that's really fun because like you you don't
identify with a lot of characters but you've got
like Batman and I I love that Batman can be that
yeah totally and and I think it's it's a it's
a nice human element because I think who's it
Plastic Man uh at one point says that thing about
like you're just a guy in a suit do you like the
rest of us are powered and and so I think that
combined with the fact that sure he is human he's
wrong sometimes he does you know let his like
it's a great Counterpoint that Superman should
be blinded by rage Vengeance and hurt Etc because
yeah like Bruce making these ideological arguments
like yeah he's not perfect but also I think that
bolsters his position in a way it's actually
really funny that this is the comic I'm about
to reference because it's also written by Tom
Taylor this dude's incredible uh last month's
uh There's a comic I've told you about before
called Batman one bad day and I reference Riddler
before last month the final issue of the seven
issue Anthology series they're not connected at
all each one is its own thing but it just happens
to be seven things yeah uh was Rochelle ghoul and
it was written by Tom Taylor and it was basically
how he's kind of right and how Batman is wrong to
his extremism and it was really cool because it
almost plays like an uh the opposite of Injustice
Superman's not involved in it but it's seeing how
a villain's perspective has a greater overall good
than Batman's and it was really cool to read a
Batman story where like hey your extremism about
not doing these things is costing the world and
rash Al ghoul and it's a fascinating comic book
and like it was really cool to watch this because
I don't know Tom Taylor wrote like seven volumes
of this this keeps going like there's like there's
100 plus yeah and like there's there's I think
two video games and then like seven volumes of
books wow so I think he's written like upwards of
hundreds of issues of this story and um I didn't
know like after a point how this ended so it was
really cool for me to like watch this and know how
it started and then like at a point I don't know
where it went so it was really cool for me to be
like oh right I I stopped here yeah like this was
so fascinating so you get the dual yeah that's 30
minutes being like he doesn't know and then like
it just escalates and then at some point being
like Oh God I don't know yeah no that was so much
that we could each exist yeah I really enjoyed the
opening where I was like he doesn't have duck this
is gonna get very soon because the opening is like
so heavy and then it's just it gets worse
so dark so heavy and and two like God yeah
Joker gets taken out like right away and yet
like this is all it all kind of has set him
like yeah they're really good at kind of pinning
down the geography to where you're not thinking
necessarily of him but you're like wow this
was this was the one bad day and all of the
cascading circumstances that came out of that
and all Joker needed to do was change tactics
and it's like a master plan like it Batman by
way of Superman like yeah and and The Ensemble
of characters they they chose here was lovely too
like I mean and also sorry last thing about Joker
I love that the Joker's suicidal so that works so
well for that choice for the character like that
really made me happy to see Joker be like this is
what I've always wanted and I get to destroy the
world through Batman like it's so forget to get
the answer oh man like his ultimate joke no yeah
like and that image in the comic book like it's
just I love that his last word is punchline
because he punched through that no like it's it
is like Chef's kit like there's so many Magic
flourishes that that could only exist in like an
else worlds kind of scenario like this and I like
that they even go so far as to be like here's
a little Multiverse I also like that they're
like we all sing for Earth one because that like
that is what everyone would think like I would be
like yeah we're once the rest and Liberty's like
that's kind of what we do uh The Ensemble though
like you got to meet Mr terrific you got to meet
people plastic man you got to meet like a lot of
really cool like It's tricky because I wouldn't
say A and B list but like less uh awareness like
a lot of people don't know these characters I'm
I'm yeah it's like Plastic Man as a character
I've seen yeah but I wouldn't have been able to
like identify and uh and uh Mr terrific like yeah
he's uh yeah like I want more of I just want to
see more of that character yeah in an animated
movie that's now in 20 minutes long and Mr like
that I love that this is let's go philosophy no
it's like this movie was like let's go anything
anything we're trying to do let's go like I I was
I was talking about face off the other day and
I was like part of what makes this movie work is
that anything it decides to be at any given moment
it is going full force at that and this different
way different kind of thing but like this has
that where yeah anything we're doing like even
the little romantic moments yeah like kind of
romantic or touching or like when it's actually
emotional like when when Catwoman Comforts Batman
like that's that's like really set like there were
a couple times where this got me I didn't like
cry but I was I did get Misty and I didn't like
get tears in my eyes forming up and I was like
Wow even on top of all this other you know all
the other ways this movie is hitting you also have
that and like Superman's pain and anguish and the
way that they amplify his grief and show that like
when you're grieving and you have the wrong people
in your ear yes so many bad things can happen and
sometimes the wrong people are people like Wonder
Woman Who are your colleagues or who people
you trust and then you have like your racial
ghouls who are going to and he wouldn't be on his
side mentally broke to a point like you break and
break and break and like one bad decision leads
to another I like how it's causality it's not just
like oh Rochelle ghoul I I get his perspective
no no he had to get to that point and that's very
human and I love that and elsewhere what I think
else worlds do best when they're good a lot of
Elsewhere alternate but when elseworld is good
it shows the trueness of the character because
you see how one tweak changes the character but
you believe in them to such a level like all of
the supporting characters and even Superman's
choices that only makes our Superman better
that only makes our taking those characters better
because you see all these different angles of them
yeah yeah and like it was really well conceived
of and well fleshed out just for all those turns
that needed to happen and I love that as much as
so much of this is in your face uh like especially
the Superman and Wonder Woman relationship was had
this like oddly fascinating tone where so much of
it you're watching it and going like she is not
leading you in the right direction like she's not
encouraging you in the right direction like there
are so many early moments where you're like if if
you weren't like bolstering his position right
now he might regret a little bit and ease up on
him and she's going this is the piece that I have
always sought and she doesn't she doesn't believe
that Superman can go bad yeah she thinks that
Superman's so incorruptable that he is the one
to solve the problem she sees so much goodness
in Clark that she thinks that this is going to
be a net positive even at cost like that's and
that's great writing yeah oh yeah and and I mean
those little twists of the knife like it reminded
me of the whole um Martha Wayne Joker thing yeah
when you have just these like especially with
Lois up top but but all the yeah just different
twists on the familiar circumstances that then
Paul saying don't do this thing but then because
Russia's there rash wouldn't be there without the
Wonder Woman being there Wonder won't be there she
didn't believe in Clark Clark wouldn't have been
believable if he hadn't been Clark those years
like it's so many like it's genius yeah yeah and
then watching Batman have to be like Clark you're
you're not you're not me learn the lessons I
already he learned my dude and even fighting
another Superman like he wouldn't hold back
so he would be stronger than Superman because
Superman holds back like genius oh yeah well and
two I feel like it's interesting people dog on on
Damien Wayne I feel like he has such purpose yeah
I don't know at least as of these movies like I
feel like when they announce the Brave and the
Bold and James goes like he's my favorite Robin
I feel like people kind of dogpiled that but I'm
like through these movies I have loved his Arc
and the continuity but also something like this
that is clearly you know very much in line with
all of that and then the stuff that goes down
between him and dick well I love that to me I've
I've talked about not actually maybe you'll make a
koi's comic Corner about this because I've talked
about how the reason I love Batman's Rogues is
their him one bad day away from whatever and how
they have that same passion what I love about his
Robins is they're all the alternate realities of
Bruce's childhood call yeah so like the adulthood
is the villains the childhood is the Robins
ah so I love personally the psychology of
Batman displacing his own belief system into
these children and how someone that didn't have a
childhood would do that and how Batman displacing
his anger is at adulthood and at the villains
oh that's a that's right that's some depth right
there I should make a video because I that's
something I've I've played with narrative yeah
and I think it'd be interesting to dive into it's
because it's thematic right aspect yeah and like
because Nightwing represents his maturation into
becoming like it's like puberty it's your cool
you're edgy and you actually find yourself and
you know um the Innocence Lost of Red Hood and
like wow how you know that took over and you
never had the ability to mature in Nightwing
and he represents the Rage of pre-adolescence he
represents that youthful you know vindictiveness
that comes from feeling slighted by the world
like they're all youthful emotions so the robins
are his Youth and the villains are is adult and
I and I love that yeah and like just his aligning
with Superman in that position made so so much
sense yeah and two the whole ramakrishna thing
it was again like a a beautiful sort of cosmic
Fantastical left turn the world because they've
established dead man like you you said like hello
and yeah I was like I was hoping for for dead man
himself just because discovering that character in
justice league dark was such a joy but then yeah
to get the to be so upset that they would dare
kill off uh dick and then to be rewarded with
like he's cool in this form too yeah which which
made up for I like long hair Dick Grayson I mean
a little bit uh and not to say that the haircut is
bad but I was just like oh man is my dad grow it
out dude and then you look great but yeah having
him come back in that capacity and the whole thing
where he has to you know possess Damien and they
have to fight as one and then you can see him
after that because of that it's just like so many
people only two beats felt rushed in this whole
thing and one was the The Dick Grayson Damien
moment just felt like he he Damien fought it
nine tenths out of the way I would have loved
a little back and forth and like a dick having
a little say and then the very end obviously they
were like we gotta rapid 200 20 minutes but like
uh oh but overall the pacing's so incredible in
this because like this comic is so long and they
told it an hour and 20. and it's also so deep and
dense like you said like it feels longer very few
moments felt rushed and that's impressive for
how much they did yeah and they still managed
to like have fun with it yeah well we speaking
of Russian we got to wrap this up uh this was
so much fun I love this this is in contention for
my top three uh this was so special it's gonna be
so hard to rank these we're gonna try we're gonna
keep watching them we know this was more recent
we know this wasn't dcau but we were going to be
going back to that I think next um but we're gonna
play around with this and if you guys want to see
any certain ones again leave a comment below hit
that like hit that notification if you want to
see me do that my um philosophy and psychology
of Batman let me know because I think that'd be
fun and uh anything else in that vein let us know
and as ever please do share this video this is
always fun much love to you reject Nation we Audi
yeah but before we leave future John has to
edit this into this video somewhere I want to
give a very special super sexy Patron shout out
to a cool name that I saw and I was like this is
this is uh I got a little zasket a little flavor
pandemic Jones I'm gonna give some love in this
name because one pandemic inherently negative word
but especially lately uh you know we lived through
one Jones very keeping up with the Joneses makes
me think Americana makes me think it's almost
like the more flavorful Smith it's got a little
of the uh you know it's it's a neutral leaning
positive and the philosophy of Keeping Up With
the Jones is is really interesting because it's
about finding yourself not Material items so I
really appreciate pandemic something inherently
negative with Jones which I think of is inherently
positive so you're combining this the name itself
has this very interesting Duality and dichotomy
of belief so pandemic Jones I like your name
that was beautiful I want to be assessed
that way ever yeah just having that what
do you representing I was like that was a
whole beautiful I was like Smith and Jones
reminds me of Doctor Who okay so you got John
Humphrey right you got John which is the name